The coolest one I've worked on so far. The
one that I there are several that we've done kind
of, on the team. But the one that sort of
seemed most flushed out and seemed kind of have the
best effect within the company thus far is the
we made a coaching dashboard for the course managers, to
kind of assign each student a risk index, which
measures You know, roughly, like it looks at various features
related to this, you know, behavior and usage of the site and tries
to you know, figure out how well they're doing. And also on top
of that, a sort of urgency index which then tracks sort of changes in risk
and allows one to in theory kind of group students into trends.